Well, let's go write out the answer together in the interpreter.
I'm going to start by defining my function small_words,
and it takes a list of words as input.
I definitely want to iterate over each one.
The problem definition said that we want those involving at most 3 letters,
so those are the small words that we yield.
Now I'm going to add some debugging to see if I've gotten the right answer.
I'm going to use one of these list comprehensions because I love them so much.
I'm going to print out each word that's in small_words
applied to "The quick brown fox."
I'm just sort of eyeballing it.
"The" and "fox" are at most 3 letters, so I hope to see these 2 in the answer,
but "quick" and "brown" are too big to make the final cut,
and that's exactly what we got out.
Recall that our goal was to enumerate all the strings in a grammar.
That was our super slow approach to check and see
if HTML or JavaScript was valid.
Well, unsurprisingly, these generators
are the trick we're going to use to enumerate a lot of strings
in a concise manner.